kigali is bursting with energy and life
home to 13 million people crammed into
this small landlocked country
and the new home for the first asylum
seekers to be forcibly sent here from
the uk
one person who knows what it's like to
settle here successfully is san
fleeing fighting in yemen she tried to
make five different countries home
before coming to kigali
it's more safe i can walk alone i can
wear what i want i can i told you people
here are so like welcoming
we didn't feel that we are stranger here
yes for sure it's safe country and clean
and with nice people
the refugees will be given training when
they arrive education new skills
unemployment is five times higher than
in the uk
rwanda is already home to thousands of
refugees from neighboring countries
many are from burundi like gilbert he
struggled to find work in a job market
that is already difficult for foreigners
who can't speak the language
senator
many of the asylum seekers being sent
here will never have set foot in africa
this is a world away from kabul or
damascus or london
there are concerns about restrictions on
political opposition civil society and
media freedoms here in rwanda those
aren't just the concerns of human rights
campaigners those are the concerns of
the uk government
[Music]
concerns echoed here rwanda's only
lgbtq-friendly church preaching a gospel
of radical inclusion
[Music]
a home office document described the ill
treatment of lgbtq people
as more than a one-off but not systemic
[Music]
patrick has been beaten for the way she
looks
[Music]
rwanda is ready to welcome the first
asylum seekers
[Music]
but it will take much more than that to
help them build new lives here
shinki maruike sky news kigali